bonsoir bruno pomart merci d'être avec
nous à nouveau sur lt france on a vu
gérald darmanin condamné ces violences
on a vu aussi beaucoup de manifestants
condamnés eux les violences policières
il ya eu 37 blessés côté policier se
soit comment est-ce que comment est ce
que vous qualifieriez le déroulé de
cette manifestation aujourd'hui est ce
que pour vous ça a été bien gérée à
écouter de façon générale fait très très
très bien gérée par l'effort de l'autre
pourquoi aux deux choses très
importantes pour la première le préfet
de police avait une pression énorme il a
rappelé les règles déontologiques par
rapport au travail des policiers ça
c'est essentiel et l'a dit si tu pars
d'où aujourd'hui des policiers qui
étaient sur le terrain c'était de
pouvoir être le moins élevé possible
évidemment d'assurer la sécurité des
manifestants et l'essayer pour tenir les
black blocks ont adulé ou qu'ils étaient
encore vivants évidemment été oppressés
30 de mes collègues et ça c'est une
équation compliquée à respecter pour les
forces de l'ordre parce que encore une
fois nous étions dans le collimateur
évidemment compte tenu en plus de la loi
et de ce qui s'est passé
tout au long de cette semaine vous savez
avec la sphère de sa production de 2
devra donc c'est vrai que l'équation
était très compliqué pour un lycée à
l'intérieur et surtout pour les
policiers étaient soit eur alors vous le
dites vous-même il y a eu cet article 24
controversé qui se retourne finalement
contre les policiers alors qu'ils
étaient censés les protéger
écoutez en dessous on savait si c'est
quoi on peut filmer en totu c'est la
seule chose qui compte c'est que la
diffusion des images peuvent être
partagées le fonctionnaire de police est
à dire on ne voit pas à travers les
images les écrits ou encore le nom le
prénom du fonctionnaire l'adresse ses
disques durs à lui non seulement à lui
même sa famille donc le droit de 2,6
mais n'est pas interdit pas plus à la
presse qu'à quelqu'un d'autre et le
droit de diffuser à condition de
respecter des règles c'est vraiment
voilà donc
de cet article 24 avant la ville parmi
les manifestants et en particulier type
d'accord il en avait rien à faire
j'étais là pour faire les flics poca
série
donc c'est particulier ils ont leur
existence pour ce gouvernement il
travaillait dessus l'assemblée nationale
en particulier évidemment la fameuse
commission qu'avec l'ancien castex est
complètement stupide évidemment parce
que c'est à une condition qui crée une
très une loi évidemment ce sont les
législateurs donc son député il va y
avoir un travail législatif à mettre en
place mais de façon que l'on passe est
cette loi nous paraît intéressante pour
les policiers c'est une vraie nécessité
mais parce que le gros de la loi c'est
pas forcément cet article 24 c'est aussi
une meilleure coopération entre les
policiers municipaux la police et des
gendarmes
exactement et ça c'était quelque chose
d'essentiel
c'est l'essence même de cette loi c'est
de pouvoir avoir des services de police
coordonnée et qui travaillait à la
sécurité d'un concitoyen est encore une
fois les policiers sont à la disposition
des citoyens pour préserver leur
sécurité leur intégrité et je crois que
cette loi encore une fois à travers tout
ce qu'elle propose la seule et vraie
notre police est et c'est une nécessité
absolue
vous avez entendu le chef de l'état hier
via les réseaux sociaux il a dit vouloir
établir la confiance des français envers
les forces de l'ordre or selon une étude
cette confiance ne s'est jamais autant
dégradée que sous le le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron est ce que vous l'avez
constaté également entre 80 % en 2015 de
taux de confiance 66 en 2020 avec 8
points rien que pour le maintien de
l'ordre
ben oui oui écoutez vous savez même
atteint ce qui s'est passé avec les
zizou n'est pas terrible pour les forces
de l'ordre qui ont été surpris par ces
manifestations d'un projet une
manifestation organisée sans encadrement
dante effectivement on a vu des
violences est parfois tout à fait
légitime puisque la force m d'utiliser
une façon légitime parler les policiers
et parfois malheureusement quelqu'un
dérive on met ça ça fait partie de
recevoir de maintien de l'ordre qui est
un corner en fin d'exercice est très
compliqué pour les précipiter jamais
certain de vous
tracteurs vous diront la force ne doit
pas être légitime mais elle doit elle
doit être légal qu'en pensez vous oui ou
non mais de le tourner hier
l'utilisation de la force létale et à
l'autorité nous donne l'autorisation
d'utiliser la force des forces et des
galeries raison pardon proportionnée
évidemment ce parce que dans la majeure
partie des cas c'est le cas c'est le cas
nous dire attends que oui absolument et
savez il faut quand même peut pas
regarder tout ce qui se passe en matière
de police de négatif on a vu ces
derniers jours avec elle la sphère de
ceux de ce producteur de rap madame
savez en france ya pris 2,3 millions
d'interventions par 1,3 million de
l'intervention des policiers des
gendarmes pour sauver des vies pour
intervenir sur des sur des
manifestations pour intercepter des des
voleurs pour faire cesser des violences
ou presque il ya 3 millions
d'interventions comprenez quand même que
si la police est aussi dangereuse que ça
ça se saurait c'est vrai qu'il ya des
comportements qui ne sont pas
acceptables faut qu'ils soient
sanctionnés et à ce titre effectivement
la loi globale mais qui il parle
également de la fameuse super bonhomme
seulement d'un poste va devoir
retravailler un petit peu son copain et
son efficacité
voilà pourtant vous êtes pour la récente
de 10 cm
mais bien sûr oui bien sûr il faut la
cérémonie en face encore que lycéenne ne
sont pas tous les policiers de grandir
des comportements qu'ils ont des
comportements déviants disons attention
et soyons clairs les policiers sont 5 ce
jeudi malgré une sortie il ya 1500
policière co qui vont être sanctionnés
cette année alors de façon
administrative ou judiciaire il ya des
révocations une quarantaine de
révocation version 3.4 des solutions
petites sommes donc on ne peut pas dire
que les policiers et que l'egypte ne
s'est pas trop mal
notamment quand ça c'est vraiment super
n est qu à ses pairs comme unique
peut-être plus sur ce qu'elle est
qu'elles produisent dirait un câble je
pense que son héros
merci beaucoup bruno pomart d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur arte
france